This video is sponsored by Skillshare.
If you want to learn how you can get a free
trial and learn the real life connection hidden
in The Nun, then stick around to the end of
this video.
We don’t have an official trailer for the
Nun to follow up the teaser trailer that’s
been playing in cinemas, but we do have lot
of content to analyse in the form of these
TV spots entitled, ‘Abbey’, ‘Coffin’,
‘Visions’, ‘Discover’, ‘Reveal’
and ‘Investigate’.
So on that note, let’s investigate these
commercials.
“Some enchanted evening.
The Abbey has a long history.
Not all good.
Hello?
You may see a stranger.
Valak, the defiler.
Valak.
Valak.Valak.”
The Nun. Rated R.
So it starts on this radio, which sets the
soundtrack for this commercial.
It’s a cover of “Some Enchanted Evening”
from the 1949 musical, South Pacific.
In South Pacific, the song is sung by French
plantation owner about a woman he has just
met, but instantly knows he will see her again
because it’s love at first sight.
“Some Enchanted Evening.
You will see a stranger.”
Aside from the ‘you will see a stranger’
line taking a creepier meaning in a horror
movie, the broader themes of the song within
the context of the piece also become more
interesting.
The character in South Pacific describes the
feeling of knowing he will see the girl again,
whereas the characters in the Conjuring franchise,
Ed Warren, Lorraine Warren and the new character
sister Irene all have psychic premonitions
about the demon Valak.
“I had a series of visions when I was younger.
And after each one the same thought would
be stuck in my head.
I saw a Nun.”
“Had this crazy dream.
Saw this thing.
When I woke up couldn’t get it out of my
head.”
“I had a vision in Amityville.
I had a premonition of your death.
You’ve seen it too.
The demon in your painting is real.”
When a psychic has a premonition, it’s something
that they know that they’ll see again in
the future.
Just as Emile from South Pacific knows that
he’ll see his love again, these characters
know they’ll be seeing Valak again… on
some enchanted evening.
This shot shows the Sister sleeping next to
this pool of water, but notice how she’s
vertical compared to the horizontal body of
water.
So this is a composite shot, I think the director
wanted us to see her dream and her reaction
to the dream at the same time.
And I think the dream could be related to
this other shot we see in the commercial of
Valak lurking in the water.
And I’ve said it once and I’ll say it
again, these water scenes are getting really
popular lately.
Obviously there are going to be a lot of crosses
since it’s set in an Abbey, but there seems
to be a symbolic struggle going on between
crosses, a sign of faith and religion and
inverted crosses, a sign of demons and the
occult.
There are even a couple of instances of crosses
rotating 180° to become inverted crosses,
which could be a symbol of someone being converted
to Satanism.
This might be a big part of the film, because
even the title card for The Nun sneaks in
a cross being turned upside-down.
If you pause as the Father is researching
about Valak, the text is too blurry to make
out, but we do have a couple of intriguing
illustrations.
The one on the left is a picture of Valak,
but not in The Nun form we’re used to seeing.
The Nun form is actually something that was
made up for The Conjuring 2.
Valak was an existing character from a 17th
century spellbook known as The Lesser Key
of Solomon.
The purpose of the book was supposedly to
teach people how to conjure demons; it’s
basically like the 17th century equivalent
of a Lance Stewart video
“Anyone out there that we can speak to,
please, we’re in need of help, I don’t
know what else to do, we keep getting somebody
that says goodbye, we’re trying to talk.
Please is there anyone there?
Yes or no?
Bro!
Again!”
and it’s also the book that details King
Paimon from another recent horror movie: Hereditary.
Which I also have a Things You Missed on.
But in The Lesser Key of Solomon, Valak is
described as a terrifying demon-child with
wings, riding on a two-headed Dragon.
It’s possible that this drawing of Valak
is more of a reference to that; Valak’s
true form and that The Nun is just an alternate.
This other picture appears to be a redead
from Ocarina of Time with a giant serpent
coming out of his face, so maybe that’s
like a third form of Valak.
Here’s the next Thing You Missed.
Did you see it?
Let me slow that down for you.
Look riiiiight here.
Well that’s just terrifying.
So here’s one of the inverted crosses that
I mentioned earlier.
The fire seems to be started from a dropped
lantern.
Remember what happened at the end of the teaser
trailer?
"Hello--"
My guess is that these incidents are related,
but it could also be from this character.
The next spot is ‘Visions’, but I didn’t
find anything significant in that, so let’s
move on to ‘Discover’.
“In 1952, the Vatican investigated the events
at the Abbey of St. Carta.
This is what they discovered.”
The Nun.
OK, so for this one I want you to look at
the backgrounds.
This image shows a bunch of grave plots, this
one is a chapel, this one is looks like one
of the characters is in a crucifix position,
possibly tying into the cross motif mentioned
earlier, and in this last one we see more
graves and we discover they are out in front
of the Abbey.
The narration here almost implies the movie
is based on a true story, like all the Conjuring
films, but also like all the Conjuring films,
the story is clearly fiction, but there are
some true characters places and events.
In this case, the setting.
The Abbey of St. Carta in Romania is a real
place and some tourism websites claim that
it is haunted.
The Abbey was home to The Order of the Cistercians,
a group of Roman-Catholic monks and nuns who
became known as The White Monks, because of
the color of their garb.
They all died in their mid-30s due to extreme
fasting practices and poor living conditions
and were buried inside the Abbey.
Priests and visitors have since claimed that
Abbey is haunted by the monks who once lived
there, citing moving chairs and vibrating
walls.
These graves seen at the Abbey could be in
reference to the haunting of The White Monks,
and there may be other connections, which
I’ll get back to.
First, let’s watch the next spot, ‘Reveal’.
Roll it.
“My God…”
The Nun.
So I’m guessing these are the spirits of
The White Monks haunting the monastery, and
Valak has taken over one of them.
And wouldn’t you know it, he’s in a crucifix
position, but if you look closely, he seems
to be standing on a big pentagram.
You can see it a little bit better in the
final shot.
Moving on now to ‘Coffin’.
"Ahh!"
"HELP!"
“Somebody!
Help!
Let me out!”
The Nun.
So I wouldn’t be surprised if this also
ties into the idea of the burial of The White
Monks.
There’s also a little string he’s pulling
on when he’s trapped inside the coffin,
which I’m guessing is tied to this bell
on his tombstone.
Let it be known that when I die, I would like
to have this feature in my coffin in case
I come back as a zombie.
Actually, just build a big fire on home plate
at Wrigley Field and toss my coffin in.
Roll the next spot.
“Here to investigate the death of a Nun.
On September 7th.
Witness the darkest chapter.
Valak the defiler.
In The Conjuring universe.”
The Nun.
If you pause and look at these lighting fixtures,
they appear to possibly be the winged child
form of Valak.
And if you pause on this shot, you’ll see
that this is the door that I talked about
when I did the episode on The Nun teaser trailer
that says ‘Finit Hic Deo’ or God ends
here.
It may lead to the corridor first scene at
the end of Annabelle creation.
One of the legends about The White Monks tell
about a tunnel that was dug from the Abbey to
a nearby river, that could have been used
to escape in the event of an invasion.
Perhaps this corridor is supposed to be that
very tunnel.
I do get questions from time to time asking
about how I make these videos, and how to
be a YouTuber and stuff -- so I’ve decided
to partner with Skillshare to hook you all
up with an amazing free offer.
Skillshare is an online learning platform
where you can take classes directly from the
experts in your field, and it doesn’t just
have to be technical skills; you can learn
fun stuff that you’ll use all the time like
how to build out your Instagram, or how to
photoshop yourself into a horror movie image.
There’s literally a class for that.
This could be you.
And the great thing about Skillshare is you
actually have people who know what they’re
doing.
I think we’ve all tried to look up tutorials
before and ended up getting something from
some 8-year old kid from the UK and you can’t
understand what the heck he’s saying cause
he’s recording in an actual tin can.
Well with Skillshare, you’ll be treated
to high quality documentary style lessons,
created by teachers with credentials.
And another issue with random online tutorials
is that you can’t go at your own pace.
If I am trying to learn how to achieve a VHS
look in After Effects, I don’t need you
to teach me how to download and open the program
first, you 8-year-old from Wales.
But with Skillshare, lessons are broken up
into sections, so you can quickly find exactly
what you want to learn and become an expert.
For a limited time, Skillshare is hooking
up viewers of CZsWorld with two free months,
just click the link in the description to
get started.
And even if you don’t have something you
want to learn right now, I’d recommend taking
that free trial anyways, then as soon as you
do need to look something up, you’ll just
be a click away.
You’re gonna be finding tutorials for things
you didn’t even know you wanted to learn.
So once again, just click that link in the
description right now to get two free months
of this premium service.
But that’s gonna do it for these commercials
for The Nun.
And for Skillshare.
If you’re excited to see this film, leave
me a like on this video.
And if you love horror movies, you have come
to the right place.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that deathbell for
notifications and I’ll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.